good evening and thank you very much for
joining us our extraordinary nhs
has now succeeded in vaccinating more
than 17.7
million people across the uk and nearly
a year
after this pandemic began this
unparalleled
national effort has decisively shifted
the odds in our favor so that we no
longer have to rely simply on lockdowns
and restricting our behavior and putting
our lives on hold
but with every day that goes by this
program of vaccination
is creating a shield around the entire
population
which means that we're now traveling on
a one-way road
to freedom and we can begin safely
to restart our lives and do it with
confidence and i want to be
frank about exactly what that means and
the trade-offs
involved the vaccines reduce the danger
of covid
they save lives and they keep people out
of hospital
but no vaccine against any disease has
ever been
100 percent effective so
whenever we ease the lockdown whether
it's today or in six
or nine months we've got to be realistic
and accept that there will be more
infections
more hospitalizations and therefore
sadly more deaths
just as there are every year with flu
even if we sustain the lockdown
indefinitely
which would itself cost lives and do
immeasurable harm to our children we
would not be
able to eradicate this disease
and that's why it's right gradually to
replace the protection afforded by
the lockdown with the protection of the
vaccines
and our approach is to move with the
utmost care
and advancing in four steps each
with a minimum of five weeks apart so we
can properly judge the impact of each
relaxation before you move on and you
can see
the details of all of this on gov.uk
and we will be led at every stage by
data not
dates and we will apply for tests
the pace of the vaccination program the
effectiveness of the vaccines the
pressure
on the nhs and the risks of any new
variants
of covid and therefore as we look at the
data today i can confirm that two weeks
from today
monday the 8th of march we will begin
step one and schools and colleges across
england will reopen
and teaching in classrooms can start
again
all the evidence shows that schools are
safe and the risk posed
to children by covid is vanishingly
small
but to offer even greater reassurance
we're introducing
twice weekly testing of secondary school
and college pupils
and asking them to wear face coverings
for the rest of this term
students on practical courses can return
to university
but all others will need to continue
learning online and will review the
situation
before the end of the easter holidays
we will allow breakfast and after school
clubs to restart
and among other changes on march the 8th
you'll be able
to have a coffee on a bench or a picnic
in a park
with one person outside your household
and because we know how stressful this
time has been
and how people yearn to see friends and
family
if only fleetingly we will now go
further and on the 29th
of march you can meet more of your
friends and family outside including in
gardens
either as two households or subject
to the rule of six and then
we'll go on to step two which is no
earlier than the 12th
of april and this is a big moment
because shops
will return and reopen hairdressers nail
salons will reopen
pubs and restaurants will all be able to
serve customers
outside precisely because we know that
outside
the risk of transmission is lower
and then five weeks after that no
earlier than may the 17th
we'll go to step three and open all
our hospitality sector to service
indoors pubs bars
restaurants along with hotels and
cinemas
and subject to capacity limits
we will also open sports stadia concert
halls
and theaters and finally
provided we continue to pass the four
tests
then from the 21st of june we will go to
step four
and say goodbye to most remaining
restrictions
resuming large-scale events like
business conferences
and football matches lifting the limits
on weddings and reopening nightclubs
all of these steps will apply in england
and the government will continue to do
whatever it takes
to protect jobs and livelihoods
across our whole united kingdom for the
duration of the pandemic
and i know there are some who would like
to accelerate
the timetable i know of course there are
others who would like to be
more cautious and stay in the slow lane
and i understand both points of view and
i sympathize
because levels of infection are still
high
and we must strike a very careful
balance and always accept
that we've got to be humble in the face
of nature
but also we must accept that we cannot
persist
indefinitely with restrictions that have
separated families
and loved ones for too long threatened
the livelihoods
of millions kept pupils out of school
it's thanks to the roll out of these
vaccinations
many of them pioneered in this country
that the balance
of that judgment is now changing in our
favor
and thanks to the vaccinations that
there is
light ahead leading us to a spring and a
summer which i think will be seasons
of hope looking and feeling incomparably
better for us all and from which
we will not go back thank you very much
i'm not going to ask
chris to do the slides thank you prime
minister uh first slide please
um this slide uh which is familiar i
think to anyone who's
watched the these uh these press
conferences shows the number of people
testing positive for covert 19 in the uk
and as you can see there are essentially
two things to take away from this
the first of which is that the number
testing positive
has fallen and is continuing to fall
but the second is that the rates are
still very high at uh over 11 000
cases on a seven day average rolling
basis
next slide please
similarly when we look at number of
people in hospital with kovid
in the uk again you can see there is a
significant fall
that is continuing but the rates are
still high and they're only slightly
below
the height of the first peak we had last
year
so definitely things are heading in the
right way but remain
at a high level next slide please
and then if we look at the number of
people who have sadly died with uh
following a positive test result for
covert 19
these are also falling and the most
recent
seven-day average is 480 deaths
a day so still high
uh but falling uh and falling uh
steadily at this point in time
next slide please now all of the things
we've seen so far
largely uh are done or probably almost
entirely are done
due to the activities of the general
public
in the uk and all four nations in the uk
staying at home and following the
lockdown guidelines
but we have had this really
extraordinary uh rollout of vaccination
across all four nations of the uk and
you can see uh in this graph that this
this line is continuing to go up
steadily
day on day next slide please
so um i just wanted to talk a little bit
about what we would expect
the impact of this to be and the prime
minister has also asked me to talk a bit
about the
results of three studies that were
released today
uh from england and from scotland
so the first thing in this slide uh to
say
is that the great majority uh
well over 90 percent near 99
of those who sadly die of covid uh
are in the groups the jcvi joint
committee on vaccination and
immunization groups
uh one to nine and they're in the dark
blue and this is a study
of people in hospitals uh in the uk
and the largest group of those uh 86
percent
are people who are in groups one to four
these are people
who are over the age of 70 and at this
stage
we have vaccinated the great majority of
people in those groups
including in care and nursing homes
who wish to be vaccinated a very very
high proportion
so we anticipate that if the vaccines
are effective
we would anticipate the death rate will
now start to fall not just because of
people
staying home and obeying the lockdown
guidance and instructions which people
are to an extraordinary degree but also
because of the effects of vaccination
because people have now had these
vaccines
we're now on the middle bar which is
people in groups
ages 50 to 69 already going very rapidly
through those over the age of 65
and people who have significant health
problems
who are under 65 but who we want to
accelerate
the period by which they're vaccinated
so they too are being vaccinated early
on
so this will lead to a significant
further reduction
in the risks of people dying and this
also includes
a significant number of people who are
then hospitalized
who are not in the first four groups but
there are people who get severe disease
and are hospitalized under
the age of 50. and it's important to
understand that we must not leave them
behind in vaccination
because that is that there are still
severe cases
in people who otherwise have no other
health problems as well as people who
got
predictable health problems uh in
hospitals across the uk
under the age of 50. next slide please
so my final slide is just to make that
point in a different way and these are
data
looking at the proportion of people
admitted to hospital
with kovid 19 by age here in england
and what you can see is people over the
age of 65
the great majority of whom have now been
vaccinated make up
58 of those people but people
under 65 make up a very substantial 42
so there's a lot of people who would if
they got
covid might go on to develop severe
disease and go into hospital
are still unvaccinated and we have quite
a way to go in all four nations of the
uk but making very fast
progress now how effective
are these vaccines and that's a question
which we said we think they're effective
trials are very good to date what we was
released today
both in england and in scotland were
three studies
which uh tried to address this problem
and this is what the prime minister
asked
me to try to lay out the first of them
is a study done it called the siren
study
that was done in people who are health
care workers so young
adults under the age of 65 and what that
showed
is that at 21 days there was a 72
reduction uh of the effectiveness of the
of the vaccine uh but the vaccine led to
a 72
reduction in the number of people who
developed an infection even a mild
infection
at 21 days after just one dose of the
vaccine
and this increased further to 86 if they
had
a second dose so that's extremely good
protection just from mild infection now
obviously
you have to have mild infection to go on
to get severe disease and then the
second study which is an important
additional piece of information
from public health england showed that
you got significant protection also in
older people including people over the
age of 80
so over 55 or 55
protection just from getting mild
disease
at 35 days but if people got an
infection
there was a further reduction of around
50 percent in them having severe disease
and therefore going to hospital
so if you put them together you
obviously won't get into hospital if you
don't get disease at all
and then you have a further 50 reduction
so we are confident from these data that
the the effectiveness of this vaccine in
older people
in reducing hospitalizations is greater
than 75 the exact number
will change as the data comes in but
this we are confident that this is going
to be the case
and this is backed up by a third study
that was released from scotland
and that looked at both the pfizer
vaccine
which is the data i've shown from the uk
so far
and the oxford astrazeneca vaccine and
the headline
numbers they report and to be clear i
think these will change a bit over time
but the headlines that they report is
that the probability of the vaccines
reducing your chance of going into
hospital so that's made up of
the reducing the risk of infection and
then reducing the risk of severe disease
both of them together
was 85 for the pfizer vaccine
and over 90 percent for the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
uh and that that was remained
that that vaccine effectiveness remained
uh in those who were 80 years old so
this tells us
three things the first one is these
vaccines both the vaccines being used in
the uk provide a very
substantial level of protection from the
first dose and in fact the great
majority of protection is
from the first dose so very important
people
get their vaccination secondly the data
suggests that that that protection is
continues over a prolonged period blood
beyond 21 days
so this is uh i think supportive of it
doesn't prove it's exactly to be
supportive of
are delaying the second dose but
importantly the third thing it shows
is that we must make sure that those
who've had a first vaccine
go on to get their second vaccine
final thing the prime minister asked me
to talk about was the delay of
five weeks between the different stages
of this
uh between the different stages as
they're rolled out the next phases
of the roadmap that the prime minister
announced to parliament today
and the reason for that is that
inevitably for each one of these steps
we are taking a risk which is an
accepted risk that there is a risk to
this
and everybody in the country i'm sure
understands this
and what we want to do is after each set
of risks with a particular set of
opening up wait until we have data
that tells us has this done what we
expected it to do
have we actually ended up in a slightly
worse place than we thought we would
or have indeed we ended up in a slightly
better place but i think
the big worry is have things got
slightly worse than we were expecting
and we cannot measure that in less than
about four weeks
because it takes that long for the
effect to be seen and the data to come
through and be analyzed
so that's the reason for the five-week
gap because it allows us to see it
whether it's had an effect
and then to make a judgment as to
whether that's material
to making the next decision that's the
basis on which this
is done but i think i would like to
re-stress what i said at the beginning
on the first slide there are still very
significant numbers of people
with infections every day in the uk
there are still a lot of people in
hospital with this disease this is not
the end but this is the point where we
can have a steady
risk-based data-driven uh opening up
but everybody must stick to the
guidelines as they go through the
different stages because if we don't do
that then we will get to a stage where
the rates go up very high
and you'll find there are people who are
not protected by the vaccination
these are not 100 effective as the prime
minister said
thank you very much thanks very much
chris patrick anything to
no i completely agree with that and and
the
caution of going every five weeks is
very important because we need to
measure
so that we're not flying blind on this
we need to know what the impact of the
opening up steps are
thanks very much let's go to david from
cardiff
the vaccine rollout is going really well
but
people will soon start to require their
second dose of the vaccine
what is the government's plan for
incorporating these second doses into
the vaccine rollout
will you need to cut back on the first
doses being given or will the
vaccination program be expanded even
further
and how
david you asking a very important
question we've got to make sure that we
have
uh the supply in place for everybody to
get their their second vaccination
within 12 weeks
as well as giving uh every uh adult
as as we've said already a vaccination
by the end of
july and we do believe we have the the
the supplies in place to keep up that
rhythm and that
uh timetable and obviously we're looking
the whole time to
uh source uh more uh where we can from
our suppliers
uh according to the the contracts that
we've already
uh that we've already signed um but
that's the that's basically the
the plan david i hope that will that
will do you let's go to
to rachel from london the who
has called on countries to ensure an
equitable vaccine roll out
this is not only the fair thing to do
it's also safer so we ensure they give
the virus less opportunities to
evolve and fewer strains develop will uk
commit to ensuring a fair and equitable
vaccine rollout and distribution
once for instance our top nine priority
groups have been vaccinated
yes rachel it's very important that the
uk will continue to
support vaccine rollout across the whole
world that's why we've uh
invested in uh the kovacs vaccination
program
for giving me one of the biggest donors
in the world to
to kovacs and as you rightly say there's
no point in having
a a vaccination program that is simply
confined to
to one country it's a it's a global
pandemic we need a global
vaccination program anything to add
chris hall
thank you very much let's go to laura
coonsburg of the bbc
uh thank you very much prime minister um
there has been
progress today but there will be some
rules in place for another
four months when do you really hope to
be able to say to the public
it's over and professor witty or sir
patrick violence
it's been acknowledged very openly today
by the government that war
deaths will come as a result of lifting
restrictions
and i know you won't want to put
specific numbers on that but
can you warn the public what kind of
numbers they should be prepared for
because even one of the optimistic
suggestions is around 30
000 more deaths as a result of lifting
the rules
and while the vaccine program's been
remarkable government documents today
suggest
66 percent of people will be covered
only about two-thirds of the population
if there's full uptake what do you
actually expect the uptake to be
laura this isn't the end today but
it's very clearly a road map that takes
us to the end and takes us
uh on a on a one-way journey uh we very
much hope if we can
uh stick to it if if the the data
continues to support the decisions we
uh take at the the the pace that we want
to
take them so the the you ask when will
you you've you've got the
the key dates uh april the the 12th
may the 17th then uh june the 21st
uh for for everything and uh to be to be
open again
uh and for things that you know we
couldn't do last year
uh like nightclubs and all the rest of
it uh theaters
uh to be back up and running in but you
know we will be guided
by the data and by the progress that we
make and that's why
it is important uh also to be
to be cautious and uh to recognize
that uh it's by i think people would
rather see
a uh certainty about these dates as much
certainty as we can
give than uh than haste
and uh that's the that's the trade-off
obviously that we've got to make
on the numbers um the uh and i've been
very
careful never to put forward numbers
that i can possibly avoid into the
public domain because i just don't think
it's helpful or in fact meaningful
but i think just thinking about it in
relative terms
every year in the uk as in every other
country you get
substantial numbers of people dying from
uh respiratory infections
flu is the one everyone thinks about an
average year might be about 9
000 people a year uh bad years are
significantly more than that
but you also have pneumonias you have no
adenoviruses there are a lot of other
respiratory
infections and this i'm afraid for the
foreseeable future
coronavirus is going to be added to that
list of things that those who are
vulnerable
uh even despite vaccination uh can be at
risk of we vaccinate against flu we
vaccinate against
uh pneumococcal pneumonia and still
there are cases and there are deaths
and i think people need to see it in
that way not to see it separate from
others
but see it as this is something where
the vaccination will take the rates
right down
but they will not get rid of this and
this is something we have to see for the
long term
and in my view is likely to be a problem
in particular in the winter
for the next few winters then let's see
how we how we go
on the 66 uh thing and this is made up
in part because children are currently
not being vaccinated there's a live
question about whether in the long run
vaccination of children would be
something to offer but there's a long
way to go before that we haven't got
trials in
children we haven't got licensed in
children we haven't got the modelling to
suggest that's the right thing to do in
children at this point
i think this is probably several steps
away at this point the real priority
is getting through all the adult groups
and i think what's been really cheering
is we thought we were being quite
ambitious
in the uptake we would get on the
vaccines actually the uptake from almost
every part of society
so far has been incredibly high and this
is very good because it protects them
it protects the people immediately
around them and in the long run this
will help protect society
so the extraordinary levels of uptake
we're seeing over 90 percent
in some cases well over 90 percent uh i
hope that is replicated as people are
invited for vaccination
please do go it protects you and it
protects everyone around you
and then in terms of you know minimizing
the number of deaths it's about
going slowly and it's about us all
sticking with the rules so
when there's a chance to sort of do a
bit more that isn't
an invitation to do a lot more it's an
invitation to a bit more
and that's really how we've got to
behave as we go through this rollout to
make sure that we do it at the right
stages measure as we go along
and make sure that we pick up if there
is an increase we pick it up early
enough to be able to do something about
it
thanks laura robertson itv
good afternoon good evening uh gentlemen
um professor witte
we've heard from you so often that the
rate of infection
can't get above one the famous ah but
there's no reference
to our in the four tests that you've set
for opening up society and the economy
so what
rate of infection in the coming weeks
and months is one that should cause us
concern and for the prime minister you
seem to have had a
damascene conversion to the idea that
vaccine and testing certificates or
passports
are maybe the way to let us go safely
back to
big live events and big concerts and are
you now persuaded that's the way to
reopen
the economy safely and i actually didn't
know whether professor whittie and uh
sapatri valley think that those sorts of
certificates would be a good idea
uh on the r above one i mean i think
that
until this point in time until we had
the inevitable result of cases rising
was elderly people's cases
rising hospitalizations rising and
deaths rising
the advantage of a vaccination is it
allows us to break that an
absolute inexorability that there was up
to this point in time
and above all to protect those who are
most vulnerable from hospitalization and
death so that is absolutely critical
now we all know and the modeling
demonstrates this that was released in
the same time that there will be
subsequent to even with these quite
careful one-at-a-time
measures there will at some point be a
surge of
uh cases and r is going to creep closer
to one at every stage r is going to keep
close to one it might at
some point exceed one and at that point
we will
expect to start to see some cases rising
but
firstly the vaccination takes a lot of
the heavy lifting on this and once we've
got a large proportion of the population
vaccinated that we our expectation is
that will pull the natural r
that it can get to well down so that
will take a lot of the heavy load
and secondly we're expecting that even
from this stage a very high proportion
but not all
of elderly people and vulnerable people
are protected by the vaccination
so the tight linkage between our and
deaths
is less tight than it was but the point
of these stages the prime minister has
laid out
are to keep that surge to a low level at
the same time as protecting the most
vulnerable that's essentially the
is the twin track approach to this and
if we let things go very fast now
the result would be a very significant
rapid increase in our
a rapid surge of the virus and then
people we have an incomplete protection
from the
vaccine at the moment and that would
lead inevitably to death so that's the
reason for taking it very steadily
as the prime minister has laid out
robert on
vaccine passports i think for things
like international travel
other countries will unquestionably uh
think of
insisting upon them just like you know
you might insist on a certificate that
you've
had a yellow fever jab or or whatever so
i think that
there's something that's likely to be
important on the in in the conversation
about
international travel on the question of
uh what is the role of something like
a certificate of vaccination uh within
the domestic
uk economy there are there are clearly
some
quite complex issues some issues some
ethical issues issues about
uh discrimination and so on to what
extent can
government either compel uh or indeed
uh forbid uh such uh
use of such uh certification um
i think all that needs to be gone into
and so we're gonna have a review
of the whole uh issue uh
before we come to it as it were because
at the moment the emphasis
is on vaccinating uh everybody or all
adults and that's the that's got to be
right because that's the
non-discriminatory
uh way to to go uh but also uh and
so there may be there may well be a role
for certification but we just need to
uh to get it right um and always
remember
that the uh the advantages of testing
lateral flow testing
so both things uh together as i think i
said a a few
a few days ago i think will uh play an
important part
uh but we'll be we'll be in the course
of the of the
coming steps we'll be setting out more
as i told the house earlier on
on issues like uh like air travel on uh
on mass events on big events on uh
social distancing
and on uh on certification for full
reviews that will be
uh we'll be doing thanks a lot let's go
to sam cote sky news
thank you prime minister you've said
over and over that today's plan
will be irreversible how can we know
that this isn't an empty promise
if you have to lock down the nation
again for a fourth time
would it be a resignation worthy matter
and to both scientists
is it possible in the opinion of both of
you to have an irreversible unlocking
sam i can't guarantee that it's going to
be
irreversible but the intention is that
it should be
irreversible and that's why we're going
uh in the way that we are that's why
we're taking the the steps that we are
and
uh people a lot of people will say um
you know why don't you uh go faster or
why don't you see if you could
uh bring things uh bring some of this
unlocking
earlier if things are going well and the
uh the
there are signs that the disease is is
continuing to
retreat and for the answer to that
you you've just got to listen i think to
what uh chris was
when patrick was saying earlier on about
the need for an
interval uh between the the relaxations
the
the unlocking uh stages and the the need
to look at the data see what's happened
you know this disease is capable as we
have seen
this variant is capable of spreading
really very fast
uh when you unlock we saw that uh in
the end of last year in in january uh
we've seen how fast it can take off
uh when it get when it gets going that's
why we've got to look at the
way the vaccinations are working we've
got to look at the data and proceed
cautiously but as i say i certainly hope
irreversibly that's what we that's what
we want to do and we don't want to go
back into
another lockdown we want
security to deliver as much security and
certainty as we can
to the public and to to business and to
everybody that's why we think it's a a
reasonable
uh timetable and then the
the miracle of the vaccines is
extraordinary if you think about it we
went from having no vaccine for human
coronavirus disease at all ever
to having very effective vaccines in a
period of a year
that has never been done before for any
other disease
those vaccines as we now know from the
real world data coming out in the uk
and also from israel are very effective
in practice
that provides an extraordinary bedrock
of success
from which to think about moving to a
normality
as a result of that and the way to do
that is to go cautiously as you release
have enough time between measures so you
can assess what's going on
and take new measures to release when
you're safe to do so
not beforehand that's the path to try
and get a
gradual approach back towards normality
based on that bedrock of vaccine
effectiveness thanks
very much uh sam jason groves daily mail
thanks um uh professor witte it was
reported at the weekend that you were
unhappy about the big bang approach to
reopening schools can you reassure
parents and the wider community uh that
it is safe
uh and prime minister we've got cases
down by
80 we've got the cavalry here in your
words but you're still very cautious um
that sort of buccaneering boris who won
the election he wouldn't be waiting
four months to uh let people hug their
grandchildren again
what's happened to you are you have you
become a gloomster
why did you get the first chris on that
one uh
so i'd like to be reasonably unambiguous
on the school's point
i was rather surprised to read what i
read in
one newspaper and then reported in
others since i categorically denied it
to the journalists involved but
that they still printed it so fine so
now let me now say
very clearly why uh that is the case
first thing is every it is absolutely
universally accepted
that there are huge advantages for
children to be at school from a health
point of view
mental and physical as well as from
educational and from a life course point
of view
those are overwhelming and they are not
in any dispute everyone accepts that
and if you keep children out of school
every single one of the children you
keep out of school
is disadvantaged it was this was a point
that was made by all the
chief medical officers and deputy chief
medical officers together as a single
document
because we wanted all to say how
strongly we felt this is the case and
i'm sure
all educational professionals would
agree the second point we made at that
time which is still the case
is the risk to children is incredibly
low
from going to school and indeed from
catching covert covid
one of the few good things about kovid
is the risk to children whilst not zero
nothing in covid the risks are zero the
risks cost so much smaller
than they are for adults and others and
therefore we are confident
that school you know given the huge
benefits of school
the very small residual risk is strongly
in favor from the child's point of view
everything is strongly in favor of
children where they primary or secondary
of going to school and the data on that
i think are unambiguous
the third question is and this is the
one which led to having to
uh close schools uh this time round
as it did indeed on the first wave is
the impact this can have on
our uh and the view is as things are
falling down
much we're falling down rapidly at the
moment
and there is some headroom to go ahead
and the first priority as the prime
minister
has repeatedly said is for schooling and
i think everyone would
agree with that we have a natural fire
break
at the easter holidays and we've got
these five weeks to work out how things
are going so there's a large number of
insurances built in and the several
things we're going to be doing this time
around on schools
which will take the risk even further
down than it has been uh before
including greater use of testing uh in
wider use of
masks and a whole variety of other
things as
you know which have been incredibly
supported by uh many in the teaching uh
professions and i really would like to
pay a huge tribute to what teachers have
done over the whole period because
they've kept schools going for
uh children of key workers all the way
through including the absolutely worst
times and they've done that because they
believe so strongly in education as all
of us do
and the final thing that is needed is
obviously to make sure that as
far as possible schools are a safe
working environment
relative to all other working
environments and many of the things
we're talking about
will help that as well because teachers
and other health and other uh teaching
professionals
uh obviously want to consider that but
um
what you look at when you look at the
data are the relative to
many of the professions that continue to
work through this to nurses care home
workers
many other professions teaching there's
not zero risk to teaching in any
profession
but teachers and not a high risk
profession in the way that those kinds
of
professions are high-risk professions
but i don't want to diminish that i'm
just saying they should be made as
as safe as possible including in
environments where people aren't doing
uh face-to-face uh classroom teaching
but you know to go back to the beginning
i think there is a really clear reason
why everybody wants children to be in
school
and what we therefore have to do is try
and make that as ris reduce the risk as
far as we can
for to for students for parents for
teachers
and the final thing is uh the
vaccination that's going on at the
moment
what's called the the uh tier vi
vaccination
for jcvi includes people under the age
of 65 if you've got pre-existing health
conditions
and for teachers and parents who are in
those groups
the vaccination is accelerated because
they're part of
the early wave of vaccinations so i just
want to put it's a long answer
but that's because i think a lot of
parents a lot of families
are wanting to think about this indeed a
lot of teachers obviously
i wanted to think about this and i
wanted to give a really clear answer to
that the best i can
patrick may want to add to that well
it's a very complete answer and i
completely agree with it i think
it's crucial we get children back to
school
the environment as as chris has said has
been made progressively
more safe for children to do that and
we're in a situation now where if we can
get the children back
we can measure after five weeks the
effect we've got
three weeks before a two-week holiday
this is the right thing to do
and it's right to get that as the top
priority
yeah and jason i don't think i'm being
remotely a a gloomster in in what i say
listening to
uh the uh this this road map it's pretty
obvious you know the crocus of
of hope is poking through the uh the
frost and
spring is on its way both both literally
and metaphorically but i won't be
buccaneering
as you put it with uh with people's
lives and nor will anybody in
in in government i think when people
look at this uh road map
i think actually it's about as dynamic
as it's uh
uh possible to to be under the
circumstances and with uh disease and
infection
uh where we are if you'd said to me uh
you know a few months ago uh that by
june the 21st we were going to be in a
position where we thought it was really
credible
to open up everything including
nightclubs
uh i i would have struggled to to
believe you
uh quite frankly but that's the miracle
of of the vaccination
program that has has has delivered
that and i think what this road map does
is it strikes
a balance it allows us uh to
go forward cautiously and
not to go back and i think that's what
people really want they want to go
forward as fast as
reasonably reasonably and and safely
can and not to be forced uh backwards
again i think they would rather trade
uh some haste as i say for
for certainty and security about the
the deadlines that we're setting okay
thank you pippa of the mirror good
evening
um the roadmap promises a review into
whether
it's going to be possible to ease social
distancing rules from june the 22nd
professor witty and sir patrick you've
both previously suggested that some of
those may be in place
at the end of the year can give us any
idea when we might be able to go back to
the office or
more importantly for for most people to
hug or kiss
our loved ones or can we really look
forward
to an end social distancing this summer
and prime minister
you said earlier in the comments that
you will not pull the rug out from under
businesses and workers
um yet you've told them that they have
to wait until the budget many especially
the self-employed and hospitality sector
already on the brink
and now face are facing more months of
lockdown restrictions
meaning as the country opens up this
summer we could be facing mass
job losses can you give them the
reassurance that they so desperately
need
now
so as we get the population vaccinated
and the ambition is to have
all adults have a first dose by the end
of july as the prime minister has said
you start to get real protection across
the entire population
at that point many of these things that
we've got in place now will have gone
it's possible that coming into next
winter in particular
certain things may be necessary and tony
fauci yesterday said in the us that he
thought that things like
masked may be needed next winter and i
think we're in the same position that it
may be necessary next winter
to have things like mask wearing in
certain situations
hand hygiene should remain part of the
norm
making sure that if we get the sorts of
symptoms that we know are associated
with covid we stay off work
having an effective test trace and
isolate systems still in place
will be an important part of the
baseline measures that we're talking
about
and taking individual responsibility
for thinking about where there's an
environment in which there could be a
risk particularly during the winter
months
are the sorts of things that i think we
should expect for next winter
that's not the same as a whole raft of
npis in place
restricting movement now all of this
depends on what we see
and what we measure and how this goes
i'm not making any promises about
anything
but those are the sorts of measures that
you might expect i think as a sort of
baseline to be required
during winter months chris you may want
to
uh no on
on the hospitality sector i know how
tough it is it's been
uh for that sector and particularly for
the uh many female workers in
in that sector who make up such a large
proportion of the uh of the
workforce and uh we will of course
continue to support uh them in
any way that we can throughout the the
pandemic and rishi will be
uh the chancellor will be setting out
more uh
next week um to go with this
road map we've already as you know uh
done uh
280 billion pounds worth of support for
the whole economy
uh on getting people back into work
particularly particularly young people
don't forget there's the kickstart
program uh worth two billion pounds
on its own to help people uh into uh
employment if they lose their jobs in
in hospitality or retail or any other
any other sector
but the best thing for all these sectors
is just to get them
open again in a covered secure way
on the on the dates that we've uh set
out we really really
uh hope and not to go backwards that's
what we're
we're trying to do and i think that
sense of of a date an ambition a goal
uh will be i hope i hope will be
reassuring to a great many
uh businesses as they take the difficult
decisions that they
they must thanks very much let's go to
to to joe murphy of the evening standard
jay thank you very much prime minister
and good evening
um can i ask you all one quick one each
to finish off
um sir patrick what's the science
underlying the new requirement for
secondary school pupils
to wear masks for a few weeks what's the
data that you want to see
that'll mean they can take them off
again professor witty you spoke about
the fantastic uptake of the vaccine
but is it or is it not the case that we
are seeing evidence that in some
nhs and care home settings people are
declining the vaccine in surprising
numbers
should could you ever see it being a
condition of employment
to have a vaccination in a care setting
or an nhs setting and prime minister can
i ask you about the future of our great
city centers
places like london manchester and
birmingham
with work from home extending to
mid-summer
is there a risk of them being hollowed
out in the center with office workers
choosing to stay at home for longer
meaning fewer shoppers fewer leisure
spenders
is there a division perhaps some people
say to you
well accept this as inevitable and
maybe turn some of those office blocks
into housing other people say
what we need is a marshall plan for the
city centres around the country
to recover them and save the businesses
that are staring disaster in the face
right now
in schools ventilation is going to be
important as children go back
good ventilation mask will add to
the protection and hand washing and good
hand hygiene adds to the protection
so mask wearing during this period when
schools are back secondary schools are
talking about
here in terms of the mask wearing and
then we'll measure effects of schools
going back at the five-week time period
probably four weeks we'll have the
effects and we'll be able to see whether
things have come back
under control in terms of schools being
back and
no expansion of the um epidemic
um in a way that would mean that that
we can't can't go ahead with the next
set of steps and at that point i think
we can see what the consequences of the
various
actions are and whether mark wearing
continues and for how long it needs to
continue
as it is in the adult population and
it's really only for those children
who are able to do so in secondary
school
um on nhs and care home workers i mean i
think what people want to understand is
uh is the disease a serious disease i
think everyone who works in care homes
or nursing
or in the nhs fully understands that
secondly does the vaccine work and i
think today we've seen yet further
really clear evidence this vaccine
protects against mild disease
it protects against asymmetric disease
which means you can protect people
around you and it protects against
severe disease so it really works
and the data on safety is reassuring and
continues to mount
people want to know about that and i
think those bits of information are
getting stronger and stronger the whole
time
actually in most health and social care
settings that i'm i've seen
and the data would back this up people
are really keen to get the vaccine
there are obviously some people who've
got some caution and we need to
have that discussion with them but i
think uh
going uh you know my view is clearly for
medical
staff where i am subject to the same
code
it in my it is a professional
responsibility for doctors
to do things which help protect their
patients
and i expect that to be a professional
responsibility for all other health and
social care staff as well
now questions around contracting and not
really for me uh the only comment i'd
make on that
is there has been you know it has been a
norm for example there's an expectation
if you're a surgeon you've got a
hepatitis b vaccine
so it's not that this was completely new
territory but i think that's not really
a question for me that's a political
question
the the uh the professional expectation
very strongly my view is
professional uh medical and social care
staff should be taking it
yeah and and joe since uh chris has said
it's a political question
but i bet i want to dodge that uh
implication and just say
uh that um i think that in in the case
of of care homes i know that some of the
uh
of the very high quality care home
groups
are now looking at uh what they can do
to make sure that their staff are indeed
uh uh vaccinated but on your on your
question about
um uh the city centers and
what's going to happen uh it's very very
important question and i think that
there will be changes as a result of the
of the pandemic and
i think that it will accelerate some
trends and it may be that
as you rightly say joe there's
opportunities for more residential
accommodation
in uh in uh in in town centers in in
high streets
uh that uh which have been you know
changing the way they they
work anyway for for a long time but you
know i'm
i'm a sca i don't believe uh that
this is gonna mean a fundamental change
uh to the way
uh our life in our big cities really
works and i used to chair
tfl uh for a long time uh transport for
london and i
i remember the better remote
communication gets and the more people
can
see each other and talk on on on mobile
devices and the rest of it
as a paradox the more actually they want
to see each other
face to face for whatever reason
and and that i'm sure will come back
and i think that london our great cities
uh will be filled uh full of buzz and
life
uh and excitement again uh provided
people have confidence about coming back
into
uh those city centers it's gonna be and
then you'll get all the agglomeration
effects
that make london such an amazing place
and make our
our cities so so amazing but it's all
going to be about confidence and that
confidence is going to come from the
continuing success of the
the vaccination program and people sense
that the disease
is finally uh being managed in a way
that they understand
that it's being controlled and as as
chris and patrick
have said that it's it's it's can't
become something like
flu that we have to manage and and to
organize and
and to live with and that's it and then
i think uh you'll see
life really uh coming back to normal
again so i'm
i'm i'm a skeptic uh about when when
people say that this is going to lead to
a
massive change in urban uh life uh i
i i i'm doubtful i think that our great
cities will bounce back
along with the rest of the economy uh
once we've got this uh
this road map delivered anyway that's
all we've got time for
tonight everybody thank you very much
thank you
well there we are the uh prime minister
and also chris whittie
patrick valance the chief medical
officer and the chief scientific advisor
there
talking us through the road map out of
lockdown
as it hits eight o'clock and of course
the
the main news is there the eighth of
march is the focus
in england for the reopening of all
schools
the re return to all students
of all students and pupils to schools on
the 8th of march
there we are it is precisely 8 o'clock
so let me formally welcome
anyone just joining us now as we've just
seen the end of
that news conference at number 10
downing street led by the prime minister
of course talking us through that
that road map out of lockdown there the
most salient date being in two weeks
time the eighth of march in england when
schools return secondary school people
so we'll have to
wear masks and there will be regular
testing after that the 29th of march
is the next major date when up to two
households
including six people and if the
households are bigger more people will
be
able to mix uh the 12th of april
then when hospitality outdoors will
be able to open hairdressers salons and
non-essential retail
and the list goes on we're going to talk
you through all that during the course
of the
rest of the hour and the prime minister
reiterating time and again that he
hopes he hopes that this means
that the country will not have to go
back into lockdown
some criticizing him for proceeding too
cautiously
particularly given the success of the
vaccination program but the prime
minister
saying that he hopes it will be
irreversible
and his medical and scientific advisers
say that is why there are
gaps between those main dates because
each and every move then has to be
analyzed you've heard the phrase before
it's the data
not the dates and all these dates are
these things will happen
no no sooner than that is that is the
earliest
that they can happen and uh classic
johnsonism there towards the end
of his address uh they're saying that
the crocus of hope is
poking through the frost and spring is
on its way